[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss the secrets easter eggs and some
other references you might have missed
while watching the newly released thor
love and thunder if you haven't watched
the movie yet press pause watch it and
then come back because we're going to
discuss some heavy spoilers if you liked
the video be sure to leave us a like and
subscribe to the channel to not miss out
on any future content regarding your
favorite superhero movies without
further ado let's get started
thor ragnarok primarily dropped the
entire cast from the first two thor
films love and thunder not only revives
natalie portman's jane foster but it
provides cameo roles to both of her old
supporting characters trainee darcy
lewis is played by kat dennings who
attends to her during one of her
chemotherapies she was last spotted in
one division where she annihilated the
fraudulent sword chairperson tyler
hayward and escaped even before the fbi
could doubt her although there is no
reference to her time in west view or
any identification of what she is up to
until now we might well not be amazed if
she persists to show up as mcu scientist
professor eric selvig also makes an
appearance played by stellan skarsgard
who works out a posh edition of a
facetime chat to discuss jane's state
last but not least idris elba's heimdall
shows up in every thor film by making an
appearance in valhalla the asgardian
variant of the after world in the
movie's second end credit scene
in the comics gore's necrosword the
all-corrupting blade which was used to
slaughter gods was also the
supervillain's weapon of choice the
necrosword has suddenly different
beginnings there it was generated by the
villainous symbiote god no to assist in
his god-killing campaign instead of just
being handed down through generations at
the dawn of humanity gore ultimately
sets his sights on it thor love and
thunder most likely will not use this
variant of the necrosword due to film
rights concerns if it is a symbiote
weapon it can only be used with sony's
authorization or in a sony marvel movie
in the movie dionysus slays the former
holder of the necrosword but he is not
labeled
thor spotted donning a tee with igrasil
on it throughout his first scene with
the guardians of the galaxy in greek
legend this is the world tree which
claims to support the nine worlds such
as asgard jotunheim and niflheim this
has nothing to do with the content of
the movie but it is a great tribute to
thor's comic series as well as the
famous old norse heritage
the musical score to thor love and
thunder is packed with guns and roses
music four of which are portrayed in the
movie if you look really closely you
will recognize a t-shirt and signage
trying to promote the pop group as well
as the reality that heimdall's son has
adopted the name axel after guns n
rose's singer axel rose we presume it is
correct to conclude that director taika
waititi is a big fan
thor along with the guardians of the
galaxy assists in rescuing a planet at
the beginning of thor 11 thunder and the
god of thunder is compensated for his
endeavors enthusiasts of the comic strip
will acknowledge the shrieking goats as
tangris near tooth nasher and tank
joster tooth grinder from greek
mythology even though they are not named
in the movie thor sledge is yanked by
these mysterious goats they have the
mildly glitzy task of moving a visitor
sailing ship in thor love and thunder
the goats have now found their way
further into mcu and they have a new
routine of shrieking
for avengers enthusiasts new asgard has
been converted into a tourist attraction
the area is packed with marvel citations
along with an ice cream shop named
infinity codes the symbol for the shop
represents an infinity gauntlet carrying
an ice cream cone with six lit candles
chosen to represent the six infinity
stones
zeus and the olympians have occurred in
marvel comics for years populating a
pocket depth known as olympus in the
omnipotent city series there is plenty
of gods to pinpoint among the audience
although moon knight's conchu here seems
to be clearly missing a sharp eye
however can locate bast the goddess of
the panther tribe in wakanda a blue god
with some nifty helmet that seems to be
aztec and styling sits beside her which
might also make reference to the
forthcoming black panther wakanda
forever which will incorporate a clan of
submerged aztecs headed by namor thor
jane valkyrie and korg commute to
omnipotent city to ask zeus for a
military to halt the god butcher the
lofty celestial creatures have made
appearances in guardians of the galaxy
and eternals so it is not the first time
we have seen them do it live action
sif played by jamie alexander makes a
quick appearance in the mcu thor manages
to find lady siff beside falagar the
behemoth when she calls upon thor for
extra help and gore the god butcher's
strikes the image is taken
straightforwardly from the comic strip
gore who is on a plan to destroy all
gods with his necrosword has brutally
murdered the humongous hyena-like
monster falagar is the patron god of the
galactic frontier and the tournament of
immortals champion who supposedly fought
black holes for pleasure he was also
friends with thor
we discover in the narrative about thor
and jane's romantic life that they ended
things because they were both so focused
on work all through the medley gene is
repeatedly called aside while thor must
suddenly disappear and save the globe it
is hard to place this in the mcu time
frame given that jane and thor's
romantic life emerged to be tense at the
period and yet fury went away prior to
thorin jean's breakup in 2014's captain
america the winter soldier at one moment
he gets a call from nick fury but
intelligent audiences will recognize he
has mischievously saved his contact as
nick fury with two r's
thor's roommate briefly seems to appear
in new asgard as an associate to king
valkyrie when she is working to keep the
s guardians relaxed after gore kidnaps
all the youngsters daryl jacobson has
decided to return he first popped up in
the captain america civil war home
release one shot team thor in which the
god of fury moves to australia to reside
with daryl in the occurrences of civil
war daryl later appears in various one
shots team thor part 2 and team daryl
wherein he shifts in with the grand
master teka waititi primarily directed
them all so it is wonderful to see him
deliver pearson back in time and make
him authoritatively a part of the mcu
storyline
loki does not show up in thor love and
thunder as we already know however there
is a significant allusion to thor's
brother in the film's omnipotent city
episode when thor agrees to visit zeus
he is wearing a costume which god's
commander flicks off disclosing that he
is not wearing anything underneath it
there seems to be a concise homage to
loki on his bottom who died at the start
of avengers infinity war this portrays
loki's headgear and a shattered heart as
well as the sayings r.i.p loki of course
there is a substitute loki in the mcu
this is the loki who has used the
tesseract to disintegrate after the
protagonists journeyed back through time
in avengers endgame
thor love and thunder have a
considerable storyline encompassing
asgardian kid taika waititi utilized the
real-life children of some of his
members of the cast tristan hemsworth
chris hemsworth's son appears to be
playing youthful thor and his twin sasha
performs one of the asgardians abducted
by gore a left in amala millipede the
kids of natalie portman are amongst the
kidnapped as guardians as well to kanga
ote hinakau and matawa kiratapu
taikawatiti's children also show up in
those sequences christian bale's
children emmeline and joseph also star
in the movie india rose hemsworth
performs love gore's daughter who is
brought back to life at the end of thor
love and thunder and is eventually
adopted by thor
thor and gore the god butcher fight to
the end at the gate to eternity however
if you look really closely at the
surroundings of this incident you will
realize numerous monuments covering the
walls uatu the watcher who popped up in
the disney plus what if sequence seems
to be one of them jeffrey wright plays
him as a spectator of the infinite
universe this seems to have been his
first live-action presence in the mcu
the other figurines in the spot are
unidentified but they appear to be the
living tribunal the living embodiment of
multiversal law as well as infinity and
death two of the four celestial units
that solidify the infinity stones
werewolves are pushing their way into
the marvel cinematic universe and thor
love and thunder prominently featured
the first of them a kid who demonstrates
he is a lycan werewolves are popularly
referred to as lycanthropes there is
also a mid asian which is supposedly an
allusion to a racial group with the
ability to transform objects into gold
remarkably there has not been a racial
group known as mid asians in marvel
comics but they really do appear in
doctor who
thorne gore's final showdown actually
took place at the very center of the
galaxy in a small shrine dedicated to
eternity the sanctuary is home to
monuments trying to honor some of
marvel's most potent celestial creatures
such as the watcher and the living
tribunal the living tribunal a nearly
omnipotent object was pranked in the
first doctor strange movie and then
another statue in his homage has been
seen in loki doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness showcased the
living tribunal in a short scene wherein
steven strange and america chavez
whacked well beyond him as they bounced
away all around the infinite universe
that's it for today have you noticed
some of these secrets already did we
leave out another secret or easter egg
let us know in the comments down below
be sure to leave us a like if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe for more
content on the biggest upcoming
blockbusters until next time
[Music]